EDH Rec is a fascinating tool that has
grown to monolithic stature eclipsing
most other resources in the EDH
ecosystem and this is not for no reason
a neatly organized ordered list of what
cards other people play is a useful tool
other people put thought and effort into
crafting decks and you get a summary of
that effort delivered directly to your
eyes via Snappy UI however it's not a
perfect tool due to a variety of factors
in the first Magic Gathering video I
posted to this channel I made a point to
discuss some downsides of EDH Rec that I
hadn't seen mentioned before and while
it's a cool video that you should
definitely go watch the contents of that
video aren't what I want to talk about
today instead I want to talk about a
point brought up in the comments to that
video that being that displaying cards
by percent inclusion in decks flattens a
lot of information about the decks
they're played in if there are three
cards each played in a third of decks
it's difficult to tell whether they're
all played in the same third of decks if
they're all played in different decks or
something in between and this is a flaw
pretty inherent to the construction of
the website it's not some emergent
problem that popped up and is awaiting a
solution but it got me thinking is there
anything that users of the website can
do to adapt to this fact when I look at
a card on EDH Rec can I figure out what
it's doing there what other cards go
with it and what all that says about the
decks it's played in or even the players
that built those decks the answer to
this question is complicated but as a
process is taking me down a ser of
rabbit holes as useful as they are
bizarre and I want to share that Journey
with you today as a fairly
straightforward example in late December
I was looking to make an aggressive
partner commander deck and I was
intrigued by the commander pairing of
Malcolm Keeny Navigator and the freshly
printed Francisco fou Marauder the
appeal to me was strong two lowcost
partners one of which ramps and the
other of which filters which can be
paired with a further slate of lowcost
pirates to enable all sorts of
shenanigans EDH Rec had a mere 300 10
decks for this freshly minted pairing so
a question we can ask is who else jumped
on these two as a worthwhile Commander
pair looking at the 10 high Synergy
cards the ones disproportionately run in
this Commander pair compared to the
color as a whole offers a clear picture
almost 60% of Francisco Malcolm decks
run fasis Oracle and demonic
consultation an instant wi combo
requiring a mere two cards and three
Mana looking further we can see a bunch
more High powerered Staples also at
around 60% usage but scroll down a bit
beyond that and we can see a very
different type of card at approximately
35% usage a couple four Mana pirates
with abilities useful in slower more
midrangey decks Ramirez and hostage
taker are both fun cards but they're
decidedly not Mana well spent in a cedh
thoracal deck for this reason I'm going
to call these two cards along with
thoral indicator cards cards that give
you a rough idea on the upper bound of
play players playing a particular type
of deck if I use the indicator cards of
thorl and Ramirez I can start to
construct a vend diagram with a combo
Circle containing 58% of decks and a
mid-range Circle containing 36% of decks
I wouldn't expect a ton of overlap and
indeed a search with EDH Rex filter
feature plus some quick math tells me
that there's about 7% of decks that run
both cards and about 133% of decks that
run neither card now what does this sort
of analysis tell me me well my first
takea away from seeing the 58% thoral
play rate was godamn I guess I'm on the
right track if I'm looking to make a
high powerered deck to be clear thesa
Oracle plus demonic consultation will be
run in some percentage of any Deck with
blue and black in it but 58% is a lot of
decks well it's not a wicon I'd go for
the fact that such a high percentage of
people building Francisco Malcolm run
thoral communicates to me somebody who's
building on a budget that I'm probably
getting a lot of bang for my 84 cents
from from the command zone for my part I
ended up including none of the indicator
cards I mentioned in the deck I ended up
building because I'm a unique and
special boy for another example about a
year ago I was building a skeleton ship
deck it was intended to be a glacially
slow proliferate deck and it had all the
fixes The Parallax enchantments some
impressively slow windc cons and the
original storage lands that enter tapped
and don't tap for non- stored Mana the
commander was a card that could be
played as a mediocre removal engine but
most games it just sits there as a meme
a perfect encapsulation of the slow mass
of nothing I was doing so what de to
other skeleton ship players build
looking at the high Synergy cards the
top five are all cards that pair with
skeleton ship's ability so already other
people are deviating from my game plan
by actually caring about the commander
next up in roughly 50% of decks are a
bunch of proliferate cards which seems
sensible enough to me that's what I'm
doing after that in about 30% of decks
are a bunch of skeletons and in about
15% of decks are a handful of
questionable but undeniably skeleton
themed cards
excellent okay so these are going to be
the three archetypes with our indicator
cards for each being Freed From The Reel
thrumming bird and reassembling skeleton
we can now make a triple ven diagram and
fill it out by simply plugging in every
combination of these three cards in EDH
Rex filter tool and upon doing this the
first thing I noticed was that cares
about Commander ability and cares about
counters seem almost like one diverse
super category whereas skeletons were
definitely more distinct if you're a
freak like me you're probably also
wondering what is that other
15% I did another filter excluding these
indicator cards plus an additional one
for each category to account for slight
variances in card choice and the result
is Pirates and cards with ships on them
respect honestly the skeleton ship page
was fascinating for the opposite reason
as the Francisco Malcolm one this EDH
Rec page looks something like a tour of
low power EDH there's the players who
are earnestly building around the
Glorious card known as skeleton ship the
players who took it as a jumping off
point for some strange Quest into the
unknown the people who are here for a
commander for their janky skeletons deck
and the people who just appreciate the
card for all its skeleton and ship
goodness I picked out skeleton ship as
the commander from a bad meme deck and
it looks like I'm in good company with
that fact but the interesting thing is
how many different types of meme are
present here and honestly the process of
making this video and returning to the
Glorious EDH Rec page has only increased
my amount of love for all my bone homies
out there living their best skeleton
ship lives for our third example let's
talk about Aros Lagoon Mystic this page
has a lot more decks than the previous
two I mentioned and yet somehow it's
honestly the most confusing EDH Rec page
I've ever been on high up on the page we
get some stuff that makes sense things
that tap and untap the commander and
lands matter cards sure that makes sense
cards that lead to lands entering tapped
are good when the commander has them
come in untapped we also get villainous
wealth okay yeah I guess if you're
playing a lot of lands you may as well
have an appropriately colored outlet and
then you get down to stuff like King
marar the gold cursed are people playing
him because arilus has a mentor tapped
and thus lets you get an Inspire trigger
a turn early maybe but there's also a
lot of tap untap Synergy sprinkled
throughout the page not enough for me to
get a confident idea of what people are
doing but certainly a handful seemingly
present in a hair over 20% of decks next
up is tribal turtle decks and for this
we can see a bunch of turtles played in
roughly 15% of decks with about half
that many decks also running a bunch of
questionable Turtle themed cards we'll
call these Turtle players and dedicated
Turtle players finally let's talk Gates
the indicator cards I'm going to use
here are balter's gate nine fingers keen
and Ma's end cards played in a decent
portion of decks that you'd probably
only want in a Gates deck now these play
rates confuse me a little because in my
opinion as a professional Gates enjoyer
balers gate is a much worse card than
these other two for early game purposes
it's a waste in a three-color deck and
the limitation to three colors means
that even if you run every single in
color gate only a third of your lands
will be Gates I don't love Keen either
its triggers will whiff more than a
quarter of the time in a three-color
deck but at least it's a decently sted
creature
mesa's end is my personal favorite in an
Aros deck it comes in untapped and can
find you an untapped gate immediately
and can be paired nicely with extra land
playay effects and that's not even the
strongest way to use mes end in an arose
deck I recently posted a video to my
patreon discussing what ended up being
my highest effort deck and you can stick
around to the end of the video for a
preview of that on some level these
Adventures are cool simply because I
enjoy them I enjoy a good puzzle I enjoy
putting myself in somebody else's brain
and asking why they decided to run a
particular card in theory EDH Rec has an
archetypes feature that gives breakdowns
on different deck types but it's not
very good wow you're telling me there
are Francisco Malcolm Decks that involve
Pirates treasure and sacrificing that's
crazy I never would have guessed so in
absence of a feature like this I enjoy
the challenge of snooping around and
figuring things out however this is also
the part of the video where I tell you
that this goofy little thing I like to
do while using EDH rack is actually a
fantastic exercise that will prevent all
sorts of mistakes down the line one of
the biggest pitfalls I've seen EDH Rec
users fall into is when they add cards
that look good without thinking about
what deck those cards belong in or how
many of a single card type belong in a
deck this results in decks which have
some amount of synergy in theory but
which in practice feel disjointed and
clunky containing a frankenstein-like
mish mash of components from various
decks for this reason I'd Advocate
spending an extra moment trying to parse
what specific types of deck are actually
being built with the different cards
even just keeping in mind that there are
different decks doing different things
within a given Commander will likely be
a great help to newer players EDH Tre is
a good tool but it's not one you can go
on autopilot with to Echo the conclusion
of the EDH Rec effect you should try to
keep in mind where the cards you're
looking at are coming from and that no
matter how Snappy the UI is the stuff
you're seeing isn't magical it's just
data
slurry with that said thanks for
watching and here's a preview of a bonus
video I made about the Aros deck I ended
up building I had begun to mentally
catalog this deck idea as a failure when
I once again stumbled upon Ma's end and
this time the gears really got turning
fundamentally the issue with Ma's end is
that it's both incredibly visible and
glacially slow that slowness is due both
to the extremeness of the wind condition
and the requirement of running a ton of
tap lands downsides which exist in a
state of tension every turn of playing
non-gate land means an extra mazes end
activation that's required down the road
however these downsides can be mostly
eliminated by simply playing all of the
gates at once through an effect like
scape shift or reshape the Earth